hey leute hier ist eine interessante
frage können wir irgendwann alles wissen
gibt es einen zeitalter in dem alles
entdeckt und das universum komplett
verstanden wurde
oder ist das ein wahrheit unmöglich wir
leben eigentlich in einer der
spannendsten zeiten überhaupt wenn man
sich die geschichte der menschheit
ansieht und den fortschritt der letzten
200.000 jahre mit dem vergleicht was wir
den letzten 100 jahren erreicht haben
dann wird einem klar dass gerade
irgendetwas großes passiert mal im
vergleich 200.000 jahre lang sind die
menschen mit tierfellen rumgelaufen und
haben gesammelt und gejagt vor ungefähr
10.000 jahren sind wir dann sesshaft
geworden
seit 5000 jahren verwenden menschen
schriftzeichen zur kommunikation und vor
2500 jahren entstand im antiken
griechenland
der vorläufer unserer heutigen
demokratie und was passiert in den
letzten 100 jahren
wir können auf einmal durch die luft
fliegen und zwar wohin auch immer wir
wollen
es müssen plötzlich nicht mehr 90 der
bevölkerung in der landwirtschaft
arbeiten um essen auf den tisch zu
bringen
stattdessen arbeiten die leute an
kleinen kästen mit mikrochips die mit
der ganzen welt verbunden sind auf
einmal gibt es autobahn und jeder zweite
mensch in deutschland besitzt ein
eigenes gefährt mit dem er hinfahren
kann wo auch immer er will und dazu
benutzen wir computer im weltall die uns
auf ein paar meter genau positionieren
können nun zu sagen an welcher
kreuzungen wie links abbiegen müssen wie
comedian höchste gesagt hat wir sind die
griechische götter und ich kann nicht
mal im ansatz aufzählen was wir
heutzutage noch alles machen was wohl
nicht an als 200 jahren pure magie
ketzerei oder hexerei gewesen wäre
und all das haben wir einem zu verdanken
exponentiellen fortschritt der tatsache
dass wir je mehr wir wissen wir uns umso
schneller neues wissen aneignen können
alles bewegt sich immer schneller und
schneller
wieso ist also diese zeit die
spannendste zeit wenn es so weitergeht
erleben die menschen in 200 jahren doch
noch viel mehr fortschrittliche
entdeckungen in viel weniger zeit
das wäre jetzt die logische antwort aber
stimmt das wirklich
geht diese exponentielle kurve immer so
weiter oder gibt es irgendwann ein ende
und wenn ja was bedeutet das können wir
irgendwann alles wissen
ich finde diese frage unglaublich
spannend weil sie darauf spekuliert dass
es irgendwann einen endzustand gibt aber
vorher will ich euch eine sache nicht
vorenthalten
die uns hoffentlich mit vorsicht auf
unseren heutigen wissensstand blicken
lässt in der physik gibt es nichts neues
mehr zu entdecken alles was noch bleibt
sind immer präzisere messungen william
thompson auch bekannt als lord kelvin
physiker und unter anderem namensgeber
der physikalischen einheit calvin 1915
jahre bevor albert einstein die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie
veröffentlichte und damit alles auf den
kopf stellte
man könnte annehmen dass es mit der
kombinierten und kontinuierlichen arbeit
von mathematikern und mechanikern in
einer million bis zehn millionen jahren
möglich sein wird eine flugmaschine zu
bauen die wirklich fliegen kann
die new york times im oktober 1903 zwei
monate bevor or white der erste bemannte
und motorisierte flug gelangen und
selbst nach dem flugzeuge
kommerzialisiert und im krieg eingesetzt
wurden lange die leute immer noch
schrecklich falsch
es wird niemals ein größeres flugzeug
als dieses gebaut werden
ein boeing ingenieure 1933 nach der
einführung der boeing 247 die zwei
maschinen hatte und ganze zehn menschen
transportieren konnte und weil es so
schön war noch ein zitat einen menschen
in eine rakete zu stecken ihn in eine
umlaufbahn um den mond zu schießen von
wo aus man wissenschaftliche
beobachtungen machen kann
ich bin mutig genug zu sagen dass es so
eine menschengemachte reise niemals
geben wird ungeachtet zukünftiger
fortschritte wie vor ist pionier des
radios und erfinder der vakuumröhren
1957 zwei jahre bevor das erste
menschengemacht objekt nummer zwei auf
dem mond landete und nur zwölf jahre
bevor die ersten menschen ihren fuß auf
den mond setzte
wenn wir nur eins daraus lernen dass wir
am besten ganz vorsichtig sind mit
vorhersagen über die zukunft sonst kann
man sich brutal blamieren
das einzige was wir heute wissen ist wie
wenig wir eigentlich wissen und das ist
paradox denn obwohl wir mehr wissen als
jemals zuvor
wissen wir auch im gegensatz zu vielen
generationen vor uns dass wir eigentlich
fast gar nichts wissen
jemand ein paar fragen auf die wir keine
vernünftige antwort geben können was ist
gravitation wie entstand leben was es
dunkle materie und wieso sorgt sie dafür
dass sich unser universum immer
schneller ausdehnt
wie genau funktioniert quantenmechanik
und was passiert in einem schwarzen loch
fragen über fragen und das lustige ist
wenn man eine beantwortet auch direkt
wieder fünf neue fragen auf okay das ist
jetzt heute aber ohne furchtbar
peinliche vorhersagen treffen zu wollen
wäre es irgendwann möglich dass wir all
diese fragen beantworten wir verstehen
die das universum im kleinsten detail
funktioniert und wie eine weltformel
haben mit der man alles berechnen kann
möglich ist es vielleicht aber wie
könnten wir sicher sein dass das dann
alles ist es könnte doch immer noch mehr
geben dass wir nicht entdeckt oder
erforscht haben selbst wenn wir danach
10.000 jahre lang weiter forschen und
suchen und theorien aufstellen aber
nichts finden
wir könnten uns niemals sicher sein dass
wir das ende von wissenschaft erreicht
haben
schließlich gab es auch schon immer
gravitation auf der erde die auf den
menschen gewirkt hat aber erst von isaac
newton wirklich bewusst wahrgenommen
wurde oder atomare strahlung die wir
10.000 jahre lang nicht gemessen haben
aber nur weil wir nicht wussten dass sie
existierte heißt das ja nicht dass sie
nicht schon immer da war
wie können wir jemals wissen ob es
parallel universen gibt wenn sie
außerhalb unseres universums sind und
sich herausstellt dass wir keine
möglichkeit haben unsere zu verlassen
selbst wenn wir irgendwann zeitreise
maschinen haben und über licht
raumschiffe und teleporter die uns nicht
jedes mal umbringen wenn wir sie
benutzen
dann können wir nicht wissen was man mit
technologien noch alles anstellen könnte
vielleicht sind wir auf die coolsten
science fiction ideen noch gar nicht
gekommen
wir können nie wissen wie viel oder wie
wenig wir wissen weil wir nicht wissen
können wie viele es insgesamt zu wissen
gibt
denkt mal drüber nach
und deswegen wenn euch irgendwann
irgendjemand erzählen will dass wir bald
alles entdeckt und verstanden haben und
wissenschaft bald vorbei ist dann glaubt
ihn bitte nicht ich freue mich immer auf
eure kommentare unter video und wir
sehen uns spätestens nächsten donnerstag
bis dahin strickt